normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government let's
jump to this story from Newsweek Elon
musk's mom rushes to his defense she is
furious with Joe Biden well the real
story is that Joe Biden is targeting
Elon Musk the Deep Z is targeting
targeting Elon Musk and now elon's Mom
is calling out Joe Biden saying I am the
mother of Elon Musk his goal is to make
this world a better place pus wants to
stop him have you any idea how Furious I
am people in other countries are proud
of Elon and do not understand the US
president's motive please tell me how I
should answer them that's the best mom
tweet ever President Biden stood at the
White House Podium and stated Elon Musk
is worth being looked at when asked how
he said there's lots of ways there
certainly are the doj FAA FTC nlrb sdny
and FWS have all taken action the FCC
now now joins them it is obvious that
the federal government is illegally and
unconstitutionally targeting Elon Musk
over his political actions who is Brenan
Carter FCC who is that he's I don't know
if he's the former let me pull him up he
might be the head of the
FCC he is the commissioner for the FCC
yeah what the hell and he's been calling
out the FCC quite a bit for the actions
they've been taking and he's and he's
announcing the FCC now joins them yep
wow that's a incredible threat yeah yeah
yeah no that's that's huge that that's
major and you know it's business when
your mom goes on social media and tries
to protect you and SC the people
attacking you but that's incredible
thuggery from our government we we are
we are fullon Soviet style he writes
icarians oh he that's right he desent
okay good he says the FCC adds itself to
the growing list of federal agencies
engaging in the regulatory harassment of
Elon Musk I descent good for
him yo man but now he says the FCC is
going to be investigating them and he
says he's descenting to it he he this
guy this guy called one of how many on
the board or whatever it is or whatever
it might be but uh yo they're going
after Elon man and this is why elon's
going to double down they've declared
warn a guy with means why is Alex Jones
back because they kept look the adver
Elon didn't want to bring Alex Jones
back because he didn't want to lose
advertisers advertisers pull out and he
goes screw it there nothing more
dangerous than a man with Nothing Left
to Lose I'm not saying Elon Musk has
nothing left to lose but he had nothing
left to lose when it came to advertising
I I suppose it's fair to say there's
nothing more dangerous than the
wealthiest man on the planet with
nothing El yes yes that is that's the
ultimate version of that for sure or
who's not Fe who who fears who who
doesn't fear Fe this is so crazy man the
United States government I think has I'm
going to say it's such a dumb obvious
thing hubris like it's not that powerful
I know it is the probably the most
powerful government on Earth but it's
one of so many powerful governments it's
like you can't like win everything you
try and defend what are Venezuela as
well as the Ukraine as well as Israel
now you want to go after your own with
your richest just uh citizen like what
the hell are you doing to yourself This
I want it to be good I want it to be a
force of good on Earth I I think Elon is
also we're we're a little ways off of
being the force of good on Earth what
what kind of drugs are you smoking if
you think
government can't be good government has
never been good it's always horrible
it's always bad but I think Elon is
banking on a major election shift
because if if let's just say a
republican gets into the executive
office he's going to make sure all of
these investigations go away but if Joe
Biden is elected these investigations
will continue and they will try to
topple and destroy the only platform
that allows people to talk freely to
each other and expose the scops as the
scops happen Twitter is is the place you
go to get on the ground breaking news
coverage of events that happen now and
what better way to call out the next s
up the next kind of major event the next
the next big Pearl Harbor like event
then
of course be on social media and you see
it called out right in right there in
real time so I I I I think he's
understanding that there is going to be
a big political shift he's banking on
the Republicans the Republicans probably
will win and then he's going to be saved
by them that's because there is still a
lot of fear of you know Apple could come
in and kill off Twitter X as an app and
that is a major major issue Google
Google can too and absolutely all these
things and and that's where it was too
big to fail quot unquote and correct
functionally but people would Apple
would never do it because people would
ditch their iPhones a lot of people
would I I mean we still can't get
Republicans to vote in primary so I
don't know how far they're willing to go
to fight for things I agree or
percentage of them because screen time
for for X is so high it's not a question
of I'm going to take a stand it's a
question of oh man what did what did
they say I I got to get a different
phone yeah it's not even a question just
use the web version or whatever yeah if
Apple removes it'll hurt traffic and you
could it would but a lot of people would
be like yo I'm on this app 247 WTF mate
yeah i' like ruin my life I'm going to
watch it all day long on Twitter just to
just to teach the government a lesson or
apple this is why they made threads they
were hoping people would switch but they
will not no one cared well this is why
there's even talks of Elon creating his
own phone and if he does then of course
when
Apple everyone's going to go there but
then it's networks what networks are
those phones going to operate on
T-Mobile Verizon probably T-Mobile works
with everybody they're like screw it
Cricket like let's let's make it happen
yeah starink Cricket but he has starink
too so he he could he could merge his
phone with Starling if well he can't now
but if he could that would be the
ultimate that would give us true that's
where we're headed incredible I think uh
starlink would have the capabilities of
um I I'd imagine a phone could get a
megabit per second through starlink low
orbit I mean the the Starling he to
spand it greatly no ST network no I
don't think so the current starlink
modules are small are very small no no
I'm saying you have to span capacity
where they are at throughout you have to
have more of it up there that's what I'm
saying for it to have connectivity I
wonder what current current load could
what what they could handle but I
imagine they could easily get um texting
texting no question Starling could
easily handle text messages what would
the delay I mean these are questions I
don't expect low laty it's like 35
milliseconds oh that's good that was the
point of starlink yeah satellite phones
that's that's definitely the future
terrestrial phones are too vulnerable
these these these landlines are can be
just blown up by a meteor strike I mean
the ones up in orbit yeah they're
they're way safer in orbit I think Apple
already has a feature where you could
connect to a satellite in case of
emergencies when you have no cell phone
signal so you can yeah and and for for
10 years plus now they've had two-way
satellite texting devices you know
elon's got that in mind that he's trying
to merge all these things into 1X unit
like the The Starships the satellites
the phones the social media what else
the tunnels are going to the shape X
underground you're going to go through
big X's no just kidding they'll probably
be circles you saw those videos of the
tunnels chip La no I haven't seen them
yet you go into this narrow tunnel in
your Tesla and it can bypass traffic
self- drives yeah it's pretty terrifying
yeah those tiny tunnels I would not want
to get stuck in one of those things are
they automate like do they carry your
car or do you just have to drive your
car drives itself through oh
okay kind of actually it's like a little
sled thing his like final product is a
sled thing you drive the car on SL thing
then that automates the whole process so
it's all running on its own rails you
have to worry about driving I would not
want to go one of those yeah neither
would I but if you live in LA and you
have to face traffic you might you might
you might want to traffic in La is nuts
dude some one day I spent three hours in
traffic going like 10 miles or 17 miles
the fear of going in the tunnel you're
going to get stuck in the middle of it
or that little thing just going to shoot
the other side yeah for a long time huh
that'd be rough real
rough what's their ventilation in that
thing I don't even know I don't even
like the tunnel like the Lincoln Tunnel
you know yeah it's not like I'm worried
about it I drive through drove through
it hundreds of times I'm just like those
long super narrow compressed tunnels I
don't know about that I was talking to
someone about this with building
skyscrapers we're going to come this is
going to we're going to come a time
there we have a a crisis of Competency
coming we're already kind of there but
we're really going to be there in 20 to
30 years a crisis of Competency and I
want I I worry about the people making
building skyscrapers today what's going
to happen to those skyscrapers in 30 or
40 years
go meet the average person that's doing
things anywhere in America these days
and it's going to get me concerned about
being on the 100th floor of a building
built by these people you can look at
China today right now and see that
happening in real time and see the
buildings that are falling because
people were skirting around these little
like building building codes etc etc you
know maybe they just don't care about a
loss of life over there it's a little
different but I think it's like more of
a they they have probably or they do
have more competency when it comes to
engineering those kind of things than we
have and I think that they do I think 30
years from now yeah so so just to go
back to the topic here I I think there's
a race to destroy Elon Musk will the
Democrats be able to do it during this
election cycle will they be successful
can they stop him can they stop Twitter
what do you guys think no no and at this
pace Trump's going to get elected and
then he's going to say thank you Elon
and elon's going to reap the rewards yep
oh and he's going to say oh all these
investigations what investigations and
rightfully so because he's being
targeted he's being attacked but uh I I
I think Elon is playing also a different
kind of Gambit as well when it comes to
the defense contractors when it comes to
the carbon emissions when it comes to
all the ties that he has uh to the
military industrial complex and to the
defensive capabilities that he's giving
Ukraine and Israel and the United States
in the Antarctica right now so uh I I
believe that's one of the reasons why he
is still not officially kind of taken
out officially stopped uh because uh the
Pentagon needs them they don't have
someone needs to ask Elon about verer
Von uh verer Von Bron's book what's the
book called uh what is it like Mars
colony or something I don't I remember
see Veron BR but it's where the colony
of Mars the government has an uh the
person in charge is called Elon oh yeah
and it was written in 1948 before he was
born um that's wild I wonder if May knew
that and named Elon and then told him
like you'll do a Col that's what I was
saying like you must colonize Mars he
was like yes mother like they told Jesus
your father is God and he was like oh
really okay well I think he ran off for
a little
yeah he went when he was 14 true story
oh wow allegedly true story he just
bounced out I wonder if Joseph gave him
his Blessing oh El you talking me El or
Jesus no we talking about Jesus I think
right yeah everybody was kind of pissed
at him when he got back and he's like I
was just doing my work hey man sometimes
the forest calls you yeah just got to go
East well he's actually hanging out with
villagers but yeah that's awesome that's
like sidartha he just disappeared from
his life as a prince and went and hang
out with the commoners for long then he
became the Buddha later in life yeah I
want to know this okay I we're calling
izing
Mars how are we going to do it is it
going to be a corporatocracy is where
this whole world is headed is
corporatocracy like cor so that's why
the the fascinating thing about verer
Von Bron's book we were talking about it
last week is that he says the person in
charge is called the Elon and I'm like
imagine what happens with uh spacex's
Mars colonization project Elon Musk is
the boss he's in charge he controls the
finances and the resources so when
people are on Mars they're going to say
hey what are we doing with this new
shipment of car go ask Elon and say okay
elon's going to get older and older and
older eventually he's going to say I'm
too old to keep doing this and then he's
going to pass on and some guys going to
be like Elon passed who's in charge now
well our the next guy we have is you
know is Bill n we need someone who's
going to be the next Elon Musk who's
going to be our Elon Musk and someone's
going to be like I think Rick would be a
good Elon and that's how Elon turns from
a name into a title thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net